when people clock into work economists
are watching going back to the 1950s the
change in the number of hours people
work has been a warning sign before
almost every recession that number has
dropped and today it's happening again
the average number of hours worked each
week has declined from pretty high
levels to you know 2019 levels and even
maybe a little bit below
but this time economists aren't so sure
this dip means the US is headed for a
recession here's why hours worked is a
recession indicator and why this
slowdown could be different
hours worked is basically what it sounds
like the amount of hours per week that
private sector employees punch in
since businesses are more likely to
adjust hours before hiring or laying off
workers these changes can signal
increases or decreases in overall
economic activity but if the consumers
are spending less spending less than
companies
or pressure they're going to first
start to cut hours if they have that
ability because they don't really want
to cut workers economists have been
looking at it for decades a scholar in
the 1980s said cutting hours in
manufacturing was so cyclically
consistent that it was a major leading
indicator
but despite this history some think this
usually reliable recession indicator
could be a false alarm this time because
unusual post-pandemic factors are at
work
today in the private sector
manufacturing Transportation
construction retail and Hospitality
working hours are going down the overall
average declined to about 34 hours in
May
that's down from a peak of 35 hours in
January 2021 and is below the 2019
average before the pandemic it's hard to
argue with the economy account is
struggling at this current
the concern and I guess it was
always a million dollar question is you
know why can't you predict a recession
or anything like that and that's because
the turning point is it happens very
fast growth has begun to slow or turn
negative by one measure and some
employers may be responding by cutting
hours like engine company American Fleet
did a huge Overtime Bill in 2021 and
2022 they were just like had were
flooded with so much demand they
couldn't keep up and
um and now they've cut all those
overtime hours and they're having their
workers do sort of like random other
stuff and preparing for business to pick
up again but yeah no overtime hours
anymore the company said it isn't
planning layoffs and it do everything it
could to keep workers
and other employers are cutting regular
hours too in June the number of
part-time workers who want to work
full-time jumped 452 thousand the
biggest increase in three years first
thing they're going to do is kind of cut
back hiring you know and come back
hiring May necessarily also be cutting
back available opportunities for
part-time work and then the next piece
would be cutting back hours
there already and then the final piece
is letting them go but while employers
are cutting hours they're also adding
workers something they don't usually do
when layoffs are ahead in the first half
of this year U.S employers added an
average of 278 000 jobs each month and
in May there were 14 fewer layoffs than
in the average month in 2019.
this has been the toughest hiring
environment we've ever seen and we do
not want to be laying people off not
we're just going to hang on to them and
ride through this by writing out tough
times with more employees economists
think workers can stop overworking and
return to manageable hours and one study
from Washington University in St Louis
suggests many people are working less
because they want to
maybe expectations about jobs have
changed expectations about work-life
balance
post-pandemic factors into account The
Hours worked indicator May defy history
this time those
um you can see that the decline we're
seeing right now is maybe not as ominous
as it would normally be